استشهد شبان فلسطينيان واصيب ثالث بينما
اعتقل اربعه اخرون فجر اليوم الخميس خلال
اقتحام قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مدينه
ومخيمه جنينه واقتحمت قوات من جيش
الاحتلال مخيمه جنينه ومنطقه الهدف ونشرت
قناصه على اسطح عدد من المنازل والبنايات
ودخلت في مواجهات واشتباكات عنيفه مع
فلسطينيين هذا وقد نعت حركه الجهاد
الاسلاميذ ذراعها المسلح سرايا القدس نعت
شهيدين وقالت انهما من ابرز قادتها
الميدانيين
واكدت انه ما استشهد خلال تصديه ما لها
عمليه الاقتحام الاسرائيليه للمخيم
وشددت الحركه على ان جريمه قتله ما لم تمر
دون رد
من جهته قال جيش الاحتلال لانه شم عمليه
عسكريه في منطقه جنينه لاعتقالي تسعه
مقاومين فلسطينيين احدهم متهم بتدبير
السياره المفخخه التي تفجرت على طريقه
معسكر دوتانا العسكري قبل نحو عشره ايام
واضافها بيان جيش الاحتلال انه تم كان
خلال العمليه من قتل ناشطين كبيرين حسب
تعبير
الينا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد طلعنا على اخر التطورات
باستشهاد نعيم جمال الزبيدي ومحمد ايمن
السعدي وهما من كبار قاده المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في منطقه جنين ارتفع عدد
الفلسطينيين الذين قتلتهم قوات الاحتلال
خلال 72 ساعه الماضيه الى تسعه وبذلك
ارتفع عدد الشهداء الفلسطينيين منذ بدايه
العام الحالي حتى هذه الساعه الى 210 منهم
158 في الضفه الغربيه والقدس المحتله جنين
حاليا في حاله اضراب شامل اعلاناته القوه
الوطنيه والاسلاميه حدادا على ارواح
الشهيدين اللذين نعتهما حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي وقالت انهما من قاده كتيبه جنين
همم ومن كبار قادتها ما جرى في جنين حسب
شهود العيان وايضا ما ورد حتى من همم
الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي ان قوات
اسرائيليه تسللت مشكله من همم همم وحده
دوف دوفان وكذلك وهمم دوريه خروب كمان
يسمونها وقوات من الامن العام الشباب
تسللت من منطقه وادي برقين الى منطقه
الهدف في مخيم الجنين في مح- هي تقول
وتحتل تقول انها كانت في عمليه اعتقالات
لمطلوبين حسب تعبيرها وان اشتباكات اندلعت
مع قواتها وتمكنت من قتل السعدي والزبيدي
دارت حسب شهود العيان دارت اشتباكات ضاريه
في المكان قوات الاحتلال دعت ان ايا من
جنودها لم يصب باذهب وانها تمكنت ايضا من
اعتقال اربعه اخرين قبل انسحابها من همم
المنطقه همم قوات الاحتلال كانت قد ثلاث
اسطح المنازل واحتلتها في محيط تلك
المنطقه بالمناسبه هي نفس المنطقه التي
استشهدت فيها الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله
عندما استهدفها جنود الاحتلال بان المعركه
وقعت في منطقه مقبره الشهداء اقوى في حي
الهدف عند المدخل الغربي لمخيم جنين وقوات
الاحتلال كانت قد احتلت هذه المنطقه
واستولت عليها بالكامل بعد منتصف الليل
واستمر
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه هذه استمرت
نحو ساعتين انتهت بالشهدين الزبيدي
والسعدي واعتقال اربعه وجرح اخر واعتقال
اخرين بطبيعه الحال وانسحبت من المكان كما
قلت جنين وبقرار من القوى الوطنيه
والاسلاميه تشهد اضراب حدادا وسيتم خلال
ساعتين المقبلتين تشييع جثامين الشهيدين
اللذين يوصفان بانهما من كبار قاده كتيبه
جنين وهناك من الجهاد الاسلامي يقول ان
محمد امين السعدي وهو في السادسه والعشرين
من عمره
هو قائد كتيبه جنين التي تؤطر ااه قوى
المقاومه في منطقه جنين وانهما قتل خلال
اشتباك مع قوات الاحتلال شكرا جزيلا لك
مدير المكتب الجزيره من رام الله وليد
العمري